not for 50 years has a spacecraft built
for humans been so far from home Earth
is fast receding into the black curtain
of space as Orion heads for the moon a
1.3 million mile test mission without a
crew
three two one booster's indignation
and liftoff of Artemis one
and the journey began on launch pad 39b
of Kennedy Space Center
We rise together back to the moon and
Beyond the most powerful rocket ever
built thundered into the Florida Sky
liftoff for a new lunar program that
should see astronauts land on the
surface once again in just three years
and for the first time the launch
director was a woman we are all part of
something incredibly special the first
launch of Artemis
the first step in returning our country
to the Moon
and on to Mars
Orion's Journey To The Moon will take
around a week it will orbit several
times coming as close as 60 miles to the
surface and as far away as 40 000
further into deep space than any other
craft built to take humans roughly two
weeks later Orion will head home
barreling into the atmosphere at almost
25
000 miles an hour and splashing down off
the coast of California on December the
11th Orion is carrying three test
dummies covered in sensors that measure
g-force's vibration and Cosmic radiation
to confirm the ride will be safe for
humans the Artemis program is costing 93
billion dollars but scientists say it's
worth it so much to learn from the Moon
in terms of science
um it is a unique record of the solar
system so it tells us about how the
Earth evolved how it will evolve in the
future and by sending humans there to to
collect rocks to do the geology we will
find exciting things our team is Will
land the first woman and first person of
color on the moon it's not just the
technology that has changed since the
Apollo missions half a century ago
Thomas More Sky News